welcome to the inaugural meeting of the
community well-being committee
I'd also like to welcome long air
virtual viewers as well
and because we're a well-being committee
I'd just like to acknowledge the
devastation in the North Island at the
moment there's been a loss of loved ones
and Lifestyles and
total devastation in some areas so we we
send them our heartfelt sympathy
thank you
the community wellbeing committee will
meet three monthly and it is a platform
for ewe and Community engagement which
will include also some external agencies
and their presentations
so the format is actually to shape the
council decision making around items
that are important to our community
that will feed into our long-term plan
an example is item one that we have on
the agenda today that is an idea that's
been put forward by Mark and we will
hear about that shortly
also it would be really great and the
managers reports to have some ideas and
discussion points to generate some of
the community engagement that we that we
would like through this committee
so with that I'd just like to call for
apologies please
there are no apologies to this they're
sorry psychedness um there will be an
apology from uh either councilor
Stringer or counselor uh mechanel if
they're on this committee neither of
them are no
no apologies do we have any conflicts of
interest as we'll be discussing finances
no conflicts of interest is there any
urgent late business
no urgent late business
um well first up I'd just like to ask
for nominations for a deputy chair to
take this position
if I'm unavailable
is any offers of being a deputy
okay
let's see
so councilor Reed um would you be
interested in being my deputy
oh thank you um councilor Dixon at this
stage I
possibly not with work commitments thank
you
oh well we'll just
counselor Hotel
if I can assist and Under The Local
Government Act it is not mandatory to
have a deputy it's more convenience in
terms of if you are not here who then
sits in the chair and if there is no
Deputy then those people present at the
meeting decide amongst themselves who
will achieve the meeting it's always
helpful if you can advise someone prior
to the meeting that um uh you won't be
present until they've got time to
prepare for that cheer role but it's not
mandatory okay that sounds like a good
plan
if I may offer support as well I'm more
than happy to to do the same thing as I
did for Stewart today and step in um if
need be as a default
um but if there are any counselor who
feel on the day that they would like to
step in more than it's over me then
that's that's fine too thank you
so just move on into item one
which is the request for funding from
incent coin insert coin to play the
charitable Trust
there needs to be an amendment to this
recommendation
because simply because we're not all the
councilors are on this committee so we
can't make a council decision
so the amendment will be that the
community wellbeing committee endorsed
the proposal and Grant the funding
request for 24 360 in principle
in bullet point two that the community
well-being committee recommend to
council that it considered the funding
request from insert coin to pay
charitable Trust of twenty four thousand
three hundred and sixty is part of the
long-term plan
2023-24 development and deliberation and
notes have approved the funding will be
available effective from the first of
July 2023.
I'll just opened it up to discussions
[Music]
not long-term plan annual plan annual
plan yes so
thank you
so mark would you like to speak to this
item please
uh thank you madam chair good afternoon
everyone
and firstly I'd like to introduce James
Wards from the insert coin to play
charitable trust and your call
um we're standing up here so that
everyone at home can see us as well
um so the purpose of the cover report
that we've submitted is to table a
request for funding from the insert coin
to play charitable Trust
and to provide information and data to
assist the Council in evaluating the
Merit of this request
you'll see in the introduction the
funding applied for as outlined in uh
page six of the agenda
um would enable the insert coin to play
charitable trust to contract your core
to provide monthly opportunities for
youth in the district to attend already
very well supported gaming events
I have to add here that there is a real
real concern
that these opportunities will no longer
continue in the gore District without
any funding
these events provide a forum where youth
can interact
learn teamwork develop technology skills
cooperate compete and form friendships
as outlined in page 8 of the funding
proposal what on the agenda
we really want to talk about to stress
how these events can help to alleviate
some of the health issues we see in
society including the gore District
you'll see there are some very very
disturbing key points that we've listed
here
um these health issues include
social anxiety affecting one in three
adolescents between 13 and 18 years old
but can also start in pre-teen years
according to the health promotion agency
this social anxiety can be exacerbated
by social media and isolation and mental
distress is at its highest amongst young
people 15 to 24 years old
the correlation between that isolation
and the anxiety is complicated and the
anxiety causes isolation itself and
anxiety sorry isolation can cause the
anxiety as well
50 percent of mental illness Begins by
age 14 and three quarters Begins by age
24 according to psychiatry.org
tefatto Aura have recently reported that
in the 2122 Financial year The Five-Year
age group with the highest rate of
suspected self-inflicted deaths in
aotearoa was the 20 to 24 age group
looking more locally now
Southern Health New Zealand data shows
that as of June 2021 21.3 of the total
Southern population percent that is
sorry
accessing mental health and Addiction
Services were under the age of 20.
an evaluation of the hokanui huanui
project recently reported an increase in
people seeking specialist mental health
support
and can I just say here we're aware that
there is an awful lot of good work going
on locally through organizations such as
the hokanui huanui and other Mental
Health Services
but I think it's fair to say that this
is done on an individual basis it's
preventative health and not
um
it is prevented itself but what we are
proposing through James's
um your core is
um not seeing the ambulance at the
bottom of the cliff
I'm going to move on to a possible
solution with that said
so insert coin to play
and your core agree that students are
already gaming at home
they can game for too long
they can isolate themselves through
gaming and need to get outside to
explore and play as well
they agree there needs to be a
transition from Individual play that we
see to community play
and that is what this is all about and
it provides that balance
they model gaming as good in a more
social setting and provide a forum for
social gaming which results in a sense
of belonging and of well-being and
resulting mental well-being
they also believe that Esports or gaming
provide a positive and safe medium to
deal with life issues an inclusive sense
of community for all valuable social
connections blind to external prejudices
a sense of community specific to their
interests and sporting values and a
pathway into a traditional support
and of course supports their mental
well-being
and James Wood will talk more about
those Community benefits
some interesting data for you
um with so many people currently gaming
in New Zealand
3.7 million people
there are a number of high school teams
up and down the country participating in
gaming events
by 2024 streaming and watching Esports
is expected to reach a global audience
of
577 million overtaking rugby
I believe the drop in the number of
people watching Wales play at the moment
would bring that about and not going so
well at the moment
um
so the only research that we've both
done around the gaming was quite frankly
quite negative
but there has been a certain shift
um towards a more positive outlook in
the benefits of gaming
um
a recent survey done in 2022 by the Bond
University in Queensland Australia talks
about how New zealanders View gaming as
very favorable and the belief in the
benefits as well and that was carried
out with 1 000 participants so quite a
broad overview
um
when we talk about social media as well
um a report by Mashable National
research group and Ian marketer talks
about the gaming space has actually
become the new social Gathering Place
and with those figures that we've
already mentioned it's easy to see why
that's happened
another benefit of this awesome
initiative of James's as well is that
um
they talk in his uh proposal on page 10
of the agenda about how
a number of students that work within
not only support his events but they
Salvage and recycle a large amount of
E-Waste locally
and that's done by the youth themselves
to create more gaming computers for
others moving forward
but that also enables them to learn some
valuable Computing skills as well which
can take them on moving forward
I'm going to hand over to James now to
talk about some more specifics as well
thank you
thank you very much Mark record the
introduction so I am James Wards uh
there's a lot of familiar faces in this
room today where I've had the
opportunity to um talk to you over the
years I think we started sometime in
March 2017 with Gore corpse
um so that's going to be while back
and we've been doing events just about
every weekend
um I'm here representing the intercoin
to play charitable trust today
uh we teamed up well I've been running
my events as Gore corpse then your
corpse in various regions over the years
we found that you know there was a huge
demand for what we were doing we decided
to team up with other interested parties
and formulate the insert coin to play
charitable Trust
the idea behind the name I don't know if
you remember arcade machines at fish and
chip shops you know if you wanted to
play the game you had to check in some
money you run out of money it's game
over same thing is applying to a lot of
these kids we believe accessibility to
technology there shouldn't be any
barriers to that particularly with how
prevalent and how important it is to be
so articulate with these devices in
order to have a sufficient career path
using these devices
now I do a lot of work with a lot of
disadvantaged families and households
even with doing a lot of work contracted
with a lot of Youth mentoring for
orangutan marikia services are in such
high demand
you know I'm a big believer in the
spaces that we are providing for these
kids are providing them with a huge
amount of opportunities to make more
friends and learn a lot more skills if
you actually look at page two
caption of the year that's a photo of an
Esports tournament we did in
invercargill that was the largest
Esports tournament in New Zealand
history
of those 10 kids there for 10 11 nine of
those Lads are from Gore
our first event those nine leads came to
our first event in 2017 when we used to
head them down at the round table Hall
they were about this tall
when they first came they've been coming
every single event we've ever done since
and they have been helping me out with
every single event since they've been
helping me out with 14 hour days out at
our Workshop they live for it the part
of the family everyone who walks through
our doors becomes a family
and we employ two of those leads now we
hope to employ the rest of them as we
continue to grow we're providing career
Pathways for these fellows as also
providing educational opportunities as
well
so I just want to address the fact that
we don't spend all the time on computers
and that we set up at our events are
essentially
just a way to encourage youth to come
down on their own initiative and get
involved with the opportunities that we
are providing you know to Target
teenagers and vulnerable kids
you know we've really got to have a good
incentive for them to find their own
initiative to get down and come and see
us we need to be a welcoming environment
we need to be a fun environment you know
and given with how big the video game
industry is we think it's a pretty good
incentive for these kids to get down and
get involved
but once they start to become more
involved with our initiative we welcome
them the opportunity to get involved
with helping build more computers out of
our workshop with the rest of the crew
from recycled E-Waste New Zealand throws
out 97 000 tons of electronic waste into
New Zealand landfill every year we're
looking to cut down on that the amount
of machines that are getting thrown out
that are still perfectly usable
that we can use for the purposes of our
initiative is extraordinary
thank you
very good presentation are there any
questions from counselors
councilman Kinsey
James I'd like to make the comment that
I know you do a lot for these young
folks I know you do a lot because you
were just down the road from where I am
the different events you've had like at
the RSA Etc I know you've got a core
group of people there are you still
getting new faces coming in like young
ones Etc
you know you've still got a
what basically what I'm saying you're
still getting new faces coming along
with these young ones it's not just a
basic group sort of thing we've only got
20 computers yeah so for example our
events that are getting funded in
avercargill I put the post up on Monday
they are all gone by Tuesday
that's a Mad Dash to get those tickets
you know
so obviously you know there's only
certain amount of hours in the day
certain amount of days of the weekend
our goal is to get more computers bigger
events 20 40 60 machines for every 20
computers we get we can deploy two more
staff
you know we see this as a real career
pathway the real industry for the
Australian fellas I certainly can't do
it online there's no one else I'd rather
employ than these fellows that
are helping out at every opportunity
that's been available to them
thank you James Council
thank you James for your presentation I
have seen it a few times now I probably
should declare that I have been involved
in that as some of those um
we just look for some money before
through RSA so but uh the question I'll
probably ask you and probably the other
councils will be thinking about is so
what other groups are we looking at down
getting funding from as well like where
else are you doing here your funding
applications
um I know we've got the solely for the
gore but obviously this is bigger than
12 events just for Gore so just in
regard to other funding applications and
other money that's coming in yeah so
we've got a huge amount of demand
everywhere I mean I'm off on March 4th
to amaroo you know because it's up there
it's because there's just nothing up
there for the kids you know
um but what we're providing we're
providing you know in a space where
there doesn't seem to be a whole lot of
opportunities the opportunities that we
are providing are distinctively unique
in almost every region we go to we are
receiving some funding our events and
Bluffs we've got 12 free events funded
in Bluff by Tiffany
and we've got the impact city council
funding 12 events at the iot stadium
South and we have a funding application
currently in the lotteries commission
for Matera for 12 events
yeah or I'm seeing you guys here today
in regards to that and yeah we've got to
get some plans together for balclutha
which we're looking to get more involved
out there we've done a large number of
events there as well so
we've currently gone on the Cavs but
we're looking to get Gore
um kicked back into life I just like to
State the fact that this is where it all
started this is a distinctively Gore
initiative
this has got Gore written all over
before I started and I'm bloody proud of
that fact
thank you James councilor Reed
you cheer
um James well done I I completely see
where you're coming from I remember when
um I was the counselor on the youth
Council and you were literally then Gore
core and you did so much and the thing
that really impressed me about how you
um engaged with the kids
you didn't actually just keep them
playing the games all the time there was
there were considerable breaks and you
actually had them getting up and doing
physical activities and I think that's
really important
um I'd be really Keen as a counselor to
see something come out of this for the
kids in our district considering that
I'm sure I knew all of those I probably
don't recognize the faces any longer but
I would know those children
um the one thing I do see amongst those
people that you had
um previously presented to was the
Menzies College principal Kathleen and I
unders I read her comment and as a
person that I have total respect for I
can see that she also saw the benefits
to her community and the children at her
school as well
um and you know given that it started in
Gore and you do have Gore children sorry
I refuse that for young people
um working alongside you it says a lot
so well done
any other questions
councilman McKenzie
I might Chuck one of Mark
he knew I was going to do that
um in your opinion can you see the
benefit to these young ones in
communication skills absolutely the the
uh sorry I want to write to you again
that you know because people will say
they're sitting at computer screens but
James and you've seen this that they're
actually talking and communicating to
which with each other rather than using
yeah an appliance or a phone or whatever
you'll see from the comments I made
under personal experience that um
actually coming back a step James
supported the youth council at event
locally at the RSA where the proceeds
from that event went towards pink shirt
day which the youth Council very much a
part of
so I went along to that event with youth
councilors I've got to say I had an
amazing experience it was great fun so
did the youth counselors so did everyone
that was there but the one thing that
stood out for me actually was when James
told me about a young lad who was
running a bit late walked into the event
and the whole place just erupted and
cheered as he walked through the door
and he then told me that that person
never said a word when they first came
to the events and then this Larger than
Life personality walked through the door
and you could see that reflected by all
of the attendees as well they were just
loving every minute of it they're not
sitting there in front of computers
ignoring one another there is so much
noise in that Forum they're all having a
blast
and as councilor um read said as well
there are times when they get up they
interact even more doing physical things
it really is an inspiring event to see
thank you Matt it's a concern I have is
young folk losing the art of
communication face to face
thank you
thank you is there any further
discussion
councilor polyps
thanks for your presentation yours and
then once again I
haven't had the pleasure of you
um before
the um one limited thing that I'd like
to know is uh your time frame on on
lesson you you've applied for funding
for the 23 24.
in your plane
um
we were we are restrained and and on
budget wise and we have probably other
applications coming forward to the
annual plan and we have to make a
serious decision about who we fund this
to
um are we going to be hand strung in the
aspect of what what month you want to
start or
um are you wanting to start now or
in the in a 12-month period or are you
going to start like to November to
November or
yeah the certainly isn't that first
variety we've been doing a lot of these
events we've done around 93 since 2017
and the gore District
exclusively which sure just about just
short of 4 000 individual kids despite
those four events
so we're doing a meet every weekend you
know we slap another one up on Monday
tickets are listed promoted they're all
sold out for the weekend so we're ready
to start you say JUMP we jump
um but like I said we were aiming to do
one a month just to you know drip feed
it out but if you wanted to get it all
wrapped up annually before the end of
the year you know we've got the
opportunity to do a couple more on the
holidays during the week Saturdays might
conflict with some sport uh sport types
or certain times of the year
um yeah so we could do we're flexible
but we would like to do 12 within the
year
I guess bearing in mind the annual plan
as well then
um you know the funding could
potentially be there to start in July as
well
um but like James said he's always been
proactive about setting things up
wherever they may be
so any further
James and Mark I just
um just don't understand mechanics of of
your budget and how it works you've got
equipment higher in there let's go how
does Gore corpse and the call interest
concerto and Trust operate are they
together or are they there's one funding
the other or how does that actually yes
I started with your course and what I
discovered when I was
always done my goal to make these events
free it was always a priority for me but
I always faced that constant hurdle that
it's because I wasn't a non-profit or a
charitable organization nobody wanted
anything to do with us so I made a shop
right to set up a chair up a trust I'm
chairman of that trust I've got two
others on the trust one of them is a Dr
March and lipsky who's got a PhD in
sports science and if you want to know
the scientific benefit of gaming and
health benefits from it he's a man to
talk to he can tell you all the science
behind that we've got Jesse Hall who's
an award-winning accountant for Malik
McCain's as well on the trust
um but yeah I'm now an operator of your
course which Which is my
you know my baby since you know day one
and um yeah I'm just amazed that it's
taking the star and we're still taking
it so brilliant so just for
clarification so your corpse owns the
the equipment that's been here yeah
thank you all the computers yeah take
care of everything you know it employs
35 fellas coming in to help and run the
events basically where you want to stop
shop if you've got any these pyramids
set up where the best in the whole
country react so okay just think about
the annual plan process will The Trusted
financials available for the council in
that time yes I have had some annual
financials done so if you want to see
those on people send them to you thank
you thank you
any further discussion
you worship oh counselor Paul mcphail
hey again James
um before a few times
um one of the things I was interested in
is um while you these events going on
have you done any wrap around
um support but if you see people in the
situation where they're obviously in a
problem you know have you got that built
around and your your whole plan well
last thing for us is building that
tracks to get them from just 18 days at
the events to now being part of the
family part of the crew now they're at
the workshop and now we're checking the
can we're doing some high work without
building that trust we're a crew we're a
squad we're a group we're a corpse
but we are doing surveys as well we're
collecting some awesome information
you know we've built these surveys where
the kids love doing we give out some
stickers they do them at their computers
and we're getting some really good
feedback and data that really isn't
available anywhere else because everyone
told me The Tick Tock generation is not
going to answer 30 to 40 questions on a
server there's no way now join at less
than four minutes four minutes to get 30
to 40 questions on
we've got all that we're collect all
their data we plan to with these events
too if you guys are curious any
questions you want answered from your
youth we can get a marriage for you many
life
um but yeah it's about holding that
trust but one of the secret questions in
the survey gets to the end we're asking
a question for you to think about
self-harm or anything like that as well
if they answer
yes to that question there's a little
hint for me to come talk to me we're
asking questions in this survey about
you know do you look up to James and his
Norfolk staff you know do you feel like
you can talk to them about things that
are bothering you and I'm overwhelmed
with the majority of these people are
saying yes they do you know they're
happy to come talk to us about any
issues that they have
feeling home with our nrvs you know
okay they're just thinking in The Next
Step you know if someone comes to you
having that support network there with
us would be great to have that yeah we
want to create a foundation for other
youth organizations to get involved this
is a platform
this is a foundation we're openly invite
anyone else to get involved they're all
in the same road I'm on my device
thanks
obviously there's potential for James to
act as a conduit as well for those
Mental Health Services and counseling so
you worship and then
cheer um
and a lot of stepping on other council's
toes are you tied to the RSA in terms of
the location for a venue all right so
um we that's just where we've done them
for the last three years we were
enormously grateful we had the support
from the RSA over there Tom but we're we
can set up anywhere where there's a roof
overhead
we're under no obligation currently beat
it now
looking for marvelous menu
an awesome place
um I've got a there's a there's a place
opening just next door um which uh we I
believe the ownership under so that that
might be an option to to save us um some
money if this resolution does end up
going through
um and offering that up just as I
thought
I think I know the answer the question
but I'll ask it anyway
um and going forward this is a 12-month
proposal
um
is there any Pathways to sustainability
or is it always going to be Community
funding to fund this right does the
model
get to a scale where they're where it's
sustainable or are you always going to
be reliant on funders such as the
quarters of council because the concern
is if we're considering it and it's only
for 12 months and then it stops
thus far
where I started for these guys we're at
now you know I spent 800 bucks on 25 of
the worst laptops we've ever seen in
your life and managed to create this out
of there
I'm confident we're if we're able to
sustain what we've got going on 20
machines you know we've got enough to
get something going but if we can get 40
we've already double capacity at 60 we
can start charging x amount like I say
it's if it's we need to be charged with
60 per kid if we've got 20 machines but
if we turn 20 into 60 then we can start
charging 20 per hit you know 60 is just
too much for families to afford but if
more machines means we can lower the
door charge we've got to bring the door
charge back
but I would like to think you know we've
got the trust we've got everything we
start to get a bit more publicity a bit
more exposure you know people really
want to back it support it you know the
opportunities for corporate sponsorship
are there as well once we
set a record and really getting their
name out there
any further discussion
would someone like to put the motion
councilor Reed
thank you can have a secondary please
councilor Richard mcvale all in favor
against
the motion is carried thank you thank
you James in in in two Mark II I think
it's a very worthwhile calls and I've
seen some of the children and spoken to
them that have been to this program and
and you do a lot for mental health in
this District so I'm very pleased that
this has gone through thank you thank
you everyone
item number two is Parks and Recreation
and we'll take the reports as tabled
would you like to speak to your report
key
is there any questions
counselor Reed
hi Keith um I was just reading your
report over the weekend and funnily
enough I just come back from a visit to
Charlton Park
and I noticed the big big gap and
obviously you're going to be using that
as an exit entry point for Machinery is
that correct
tonight's severe entry point
Airport
yeah I appreciate that thank you but the
one thing I did notice it was
particularly windy and I almost ended up
in East Gore because it was just
straight through and I just wondered if
is there any way that that could be
slightly alleviated
hmm
that would be good thank you
counselor Jose Council of Richard
McDowell
I note that the parks management plans
are in the process of being updated and
the intent is that they'll come back to
the committee for final review and sign
off
um can we please have a briefing part of
the way through the process highlighting
the key issues in case we want to give
some guidance on that at that stage
okay
Council mcphail
Mr
through the middle chair there Keith
great job
everywhere I go I hear good stuff really
good stuff about what's happening around
around town and looking at your report
here there was about three items in
there that jumped out that have actually
um
have been commented on to me in recent
times including uh Donald Park the
cemetery
in Med High Ridge now the only other the
comment I have here is around that men
High Ridge Landscaping with the fact
that it's over and above the the work
current workload of you guys how do we
go forward on that like I said
going to be planned out and uh where
there's a question can be answered
either by the CEO or a parts manager
through you madam chair look on Pleasure
Rosa councilman Fowler because I was
going to give a shout out to the parks
reserves team they've done a fantastic
job
and it's now complete with the
Landscaping it's well worth the visit uh
Keith commandeered the whole crew the
whole department and blew out in one
whole day and looked stunning and uh it
was that that was a planned contribution
by the council as part of its joint
venture with the Kingston lifestyle
forever trust me thought we could do
this landscaping and Keith has got
extensive experience prior to coming to
us with commercial level Landscaping in
a residential ceiling and uh has
performed really well with this team so
I so it has been done and we have just
this today the developer all the
Kingston lifestyle trust has applied for
completion under Resource Management Act
for certification so then we can issue
title to the sections
any further comments or discussion
with someone like that to move that the
report be received
thank you councilor heisted and thank
you councilor Reed seconding
and thank you Keith
for that it's great to see the landscape
has begun around the new building the
new library building all in favor of
that recommendation please say aye
against
carried
we move on to item three
the general managed Communications
customer support
and as um
Sonia's not here we'll just take that as
tabled and is there any discussion that
perhaps our CEO could respond to
okay
or Mr Caple
or Caitlin yeah
would you like to speak to this report
Caitlyn
through Madam chair I I can try my best
although I'm not directly involved with
a few of the projects but I can try and
answer any questions any counselors have
yes you worship
thank you madam chairs and um
I just said a Christian two Christians
actually with the storyboard first of
all the lines contributing to that
storyboard or is that solely us paying
for that storyboard
do we have any
sort of joint projects or is it just a
consultation on that one
I'm sure that is a Sonia question sorry
that's cool uh and the next one might be
a Sonya Christian as well but has the
economy in consultation with local ewe
as well um on I would say it includes um
stuff around the matoda river which they
would probably be rather interested in
contributing um do we know if we've or
if it's just between lines and Council
of the stage
I'm not involved in this entire project
so that again isn't so many questions
sorry that's actually fine thank you
just asked the CEO to comment year
through eventually I'm I'm very sure
that Sonya has been working with hokanui
Renault in that particular project
councilor Reed
thank you madam chair
um I will um back you up on that one
Steve I think um I was at the initial
um meeting with the Lions Club and Keith
but he's already gone too so
um
yes it was a joint project and the first
thing Sonia said that she would do would
be to consult with ewe around the river
councilor Phillips
thank you I'm just a question about the
signs
um
are they going to be like the president
for the signs for the whole District or
are they just don't want off
Council Reed
at the risk of being shot down in flames
at another meeting I'm pretty sure they
were to be along the lines of the signs
within the district
I just got a question then it appears
that an unbeknown to me that Gore
actually is a color
and we discovered that the other night
and I'm just wondering if that color
would be incorporated in the sign
as their known color
that's a that's a jurex color rather
than our branding colors um so I think
we only incorporate our branding colors
into
um I'd have to check with The Branding
guidelines but I believe it's just the
the green that you see on there yeah
any further comments counts the Phillips
oh so then is the other signs then going
to be a standard sign for
other thing other signs that may be
wanting to put up around there
District
just just the question is that if we
ever Standard Time uh color Etc then
other groups they want to maybe apply to
put us on up like the material community
board for instance
there is then they have a known color
sign brand Etc
to run by
three and then cheer look I can't
categorize the answer but I know I do
categorically know
Sonia's view on this and she does like
standardization and
and not a proliferation of variants so I
would venture to suggest this type of
science is promoting she has in her mind
that other
um signing opportunities would follow a
similar Style
any further discussion
councilor Richard McMahon just a comment
leading on from what Neville said there
in regard to the signage I know Jim's
down the back there we are looking at
signage around the precinct aren't we in
developments so will that will that be
the same as this
okay
I just know that um
we are going to have panels and
different things that lead around
various areas there isn't there well
hopefully
Maybe
councilor Garden
is that a question
foreign
I believe there are native trout there
do you have any comment
stage
so we'll take note of that counselor
Garden councilor Phillips uh thank you
madam chair
is it's um as I travel around the
country it's probably an odd Obsession
but I seem to take photos of signs and
and uh from other districts and towns
and I have one here of Cromwell and
their surrounding area sign and Cromwell
in the in the main CBD has got
two four six eight ten twelve fourteen
sixteen eighteen twenty twenty three key
points to go to so the other thing is
that this is a specific one to the trip
um and maybe somewhere along the line if
this is going to be a standard time that
we can set one up somewhere else
and so on so
with the Pacific points
pointing down to the pump tracker Matera
Etc
just for point of Interest
sorry
you make a good point Council Phillips
I think I'd like to say Well done to
gore Host Lions Clubs for pushing this
initiative it's really good to see that
up there
would somebody like to move that the
report be received
just just one more question
um and this one I've had to be answered
in the room but around the community
engagements less consultation I see
there's a list here um is there any
further explanation of what the kind of
those may involve um more thinking about
the the recycling waste if there's
anything kind of in the near future
pipeline
did you hear Do we have any
those are the projects you're involved
in as in would oh sorry that was really
loud as in is there going to be like an
in-depth report as to the strategies
that we would Implement to roll those
out or
yeah I guess where are we at with that
Community engagement consultation or is
it more of just a list of the things
that sonja's working through it's just
very vague
um this is a list of things that we're
working through okay brilliant cool
thank you Jason can I ask you to call me
please
yeah no problem I was just going to
confirm that that was the case that we
will bring back uh to the next council
meeting update on the rethinking waste
project and from that point we'll be
starting to go out and do some
consultation on those options
thank you Jason
any further discussion
could I have someone move the report be
received
councilor hovel
engine and you worship
all in favor
against
carried
move on to item four the report from the
district Arts and Heritage creator
Jim do you would you like to comment to
your reporters tabled
ingredients
it's a very good report thank you
is there any questions please for Jim
or comments
you worship I just I guess I'd like to
say that looks like it's been awesome
project progress on the
um veraway Center you can see the work
outside which is fantastic
um I guess just asking whether that
project is uh on track um as as
scheduled if there's any any issues or
any upcoming risks
um through the chief we're really
pleased with the Partridge
control
um
thank you Jim you need for the comments
is no further comments I'm quite happy
to move the recommendation Madam chair
thank you can I have a second for that
please
so you can do a councilor heisted all in
favor
against
carried
item five the report from the library
manager Lorraine do you have anything to
add to your report Lorraine is tabled
any further discussion
thank you Lorraine I can actually
reiterate what councilor Reed was saying
and I think it's um it's wonderful to
see books on the shelves in there and a
lot of good comments from the community
so well done to you for all the hard
work thank you
item six we just move on to events
sorry about that could would somebody
like to move the report be received
thank you councilor Phillips councilor
Reed all in favor
thank you
so just move on to events
is this you Caitlin
or
Jess hello thank you oh that's about
that sorry
um
so I think pretty much
it's very simple but
um we had some very successful events
since the end of last year post covered
translations and it did become quite
evident of the capacity from a staffing
perspective it's quite difficult to
achieve the level that we are trying to
give to the community and the public
um so one thing I would like to put to
the council to consider for the next
annual plan is just re-looking at that
event strategy that you enacted a few
years ago and possibly considering a
more permanent solution to that we do
have a someone potentially lined up for
the events assistant role that is being
funded through the reserve money that I
didn't use last year because of the
cancellations
so hopefully that works out and they
come along but that will only be for one
year so it will still need to be thought
about at least in some respect for the
next annual plan
um as I've been meeting new events
organizers and connections within the
community in the past few months there's
become a real theme of businesses are
finding it harder and harder to offer
support to events because of all the
ongoing struggles and more events
organizers are now going to be looking
to the council for support
um one thing I would love to see in the
future is that we open some kind of
contestable fund that people can just
apply to throughout the year and do an
online application or some sort of paper
Form
application to ask for a certain amount
of money and then maybe there's a small
committee that considers that and then
that would also remove having to have
people come directly to your committee
meetings and do a full presentation
unless I guess they were asking for a
significant sum of money in which case
you could get them to come along and you
know argue their case essentially
um but we're looking like we're going to
have another very busy year and on the
Fly is getting a bit of a visual
to be more
um fishing focused we want to really
play on our brown trout capital fishing
um reputation so to do that I've
actually taken a step backwards to take
that step forward so this year we are
looking at a slightly smaller event
there's going to be less vendors than
you might have seen in 2021 and that's
because I want to pair back to a call
that is easily understandable to our
Market we really want our audience to
understand what the event is about we
want it to have a clear identity which I
think it was kind of jumbled between all
the different events organizers putting
their own stamp on it
um so yeah if you're wondering why it's
a bit smaller it's so that we can set a
really solid foundation and then grow on
it in the years to come
thank you jeez
any questions for Jessica
councilor Richard mcphail
thanks
uh Jason through Madam chairman to to
you I just regard regarding classic
country
um obviously it was
big news and we've sort of we had starts
and and stops we're obviously still
going to have foot carefully in their
camp and working with them and engaging
with them and because it was investment
in there and you know
where are we at with that because I see
we're looking at uh looking at ways to
further enhance our involvement and that
busting Vibe for the Student Business
area and obviously that would encourage
maybe some change in
with how we lay it out so I'm sort of
just interested
elaborating a little bit for us we were
hitting can you help us with that
so I attend
antly board meeting it's the last
Wednesday of every month and they go
through their progress and their plans
for the upcoming event
um obviously yes we do have free two
bits off busking which they're marking
as a Cornerstone event for toxic country
this will be my first time organizing
one so again it's a bit of a feel how it
goes before I start making any
significant plans or changes for it
um I think they have some really big
goals and dreams that they are going to
be capable of achieving but they will
need support I think we are probably
looking to be quite heavily involved for
a few more years to come until they
become more self-sufficient
I do think something that we can compare
to is actually the Napier Art Deco
Festival as like a cross comparison they
started off very small with lots of
different events and it was just a Board
of Trustees that did all the work and
then gradually with Council support and
then more and more investment it became
the huge thing that it is today so I
think looking
at them as kind of a case study or kind
of give us an idea of what our own
involvement might be for tussock if that
kind of answers your question
thank you juice does that answer your
question
the fact that we have really a statement
for me is that we endorsed it with um
we've invested and we've had a lot of
input there and I've decided that I've
councilor Reed can add with that but
anything uh any support that we can give
from councilor totally up from this
group I totally support
counts of reading and thank you madam
chair
um probably should have declared that I
do have a I am a trustee on that board
in the private capacity but
um freeze your bits off has always been
um supported by the council and I think
it was a council initiative when it
first started
um way back when maybe a little bit
yes I think so could be wrong but anyway
um
and I guess the thing is with tussock
country
um
we've got a great program it's increased
by about 40 then on top of the last
program the time frames expanded over
the not just
um
Queen's birthday weekend but week either
side pretty much it will take the odd
few days so there's lots of things for
the community to be involved in that
don't always relate to country music
either there's other other things that
have been organized and we are trying to
be as self-sufficient as we can as soon
as possible but of course we've only
been able to have one event at this
stage due to covert and we came out of
that pretty well with lots of interest
in a lot of repeat business when hope in
the future
thank you councilor Reed any further
discussion
oh great thank you
any further discussion
you worship
uh just a question for Jess uh is there
any requirement for Council
participation at any of those three
events in particular
that might be good to gauge with
councilors now
um or is it just a kind of voluntary
it is completely voluntary
um freezerbet soft basking would be good
to have some someone there in an
official capacity just to kind of
endorse it and show that it is our event
that's owned by us
um I do think on the Fly is a good
opportunity for people to engage with
the community if that is something that
you're interested in but otherwise
um no there's no obligation it would be
completely voluntary
thank you Jesus
any further discussion
Council Phillips
thank you madam chair I think it would
be a good idea for all councilors to
have a fly fishing competition between
each other
all standing on the riverbank with the
fly rod
I'll let you organize that councilor
Phillips
thank you Jess and all this I can say is
that people have been they were
disappointed they thought that we
weren't going to hold on the Fly because
it was usually around the fly-in at
mandible and I know that the dates
change so I was happy to be able to tell
people no it hasn't been canceled this
year so thank you would someone like to
move that the report be received please
thank you councilor Paul mcphail
seconder
thank you councilor Reed
all in favor
against
carried
so now item seven the report from the
visitor Services team leader Sharon and
I see that Sharon isn't here so we'll
just table that report
and I'll ask someone to
move that the report be received
unless there's anything
urgent that someone would like to raise
councilor hosted
let's move
paper to move in a secondary thank you
Keith of vowel counselor Hotel all in
favor
pass
item eight is the report from The
Aquatic services manager Martin we'll
see Martin is here would you like to
speak to your report Martin or we'll
table it as read and ask questions
so I can confirm that we have started
the chiller unit for the ice rink to
start producing ice as of today as usual
when you start something up when it's
been sitting for a while we've had a few
curveball Small Engines there's a little
bit of dust on me from sorting a few
issues out but we do have critical
Spears in the complex which have solved
most of those issues at this stage
happy for any questions thank you
any questions
you wish it just curious City more than
anything else when will the Usher be
ready for use how long does it take yeah
so um for us to produce ice first of all
we obviously have to get that
temperature down on the base uh
currently that sits at 23 degrees uh we
need to get that to minus two before we
can start putting water on to freeze we
are looking at about three to four weeks
for that to occur
and is that weather dependence as well
that is also weather permitted the
external outside temperature at the
moment is great for producing ice it's a
little bit cooler uh let's just fingers
crossed we don't have too many of those
30 degrees over the next we want
counts the read thank you madam chair hi
Martin um thanks for the report just
interested in seeing how you're going
with the carbon dioxide
yeah interestingly the industry that
wasn't really commented in the media
um yeah pools do require CO2 for pH
control
um currently we've changed our process
so we used to wait until there was four
empty before we restock so we've changed
that process to make sure we have some
in hand we are still investigating other
options however that comes down to
two factors really the space we have to
be able to put in a new system and also
the cost for that system so we have
currently two people giving us some
information around that
thank you um the other question is too
is when that availability of the carbon
dioxide picks up again are you expecting
an increase in costs or is that naive to
ask that
the old cost
um I I think uh what's been seen in the
past as soon as there's a restriction on
any product there is a cost increase
so that is inevitable at some stage as
to what that looks like
that'll be affected to take in whether
we pursue another option or not as well
any further questions
would someone like to move that the
report be received please
Council hovell
are you moving or you're wanting to
speak you're moving
thank you and seconded councilor
Phillips all in favor
item number nine is the travel
assistance for the Gold Country Music
Queen
this report was by the chief executive
or do you like to comment
on the stew
thanks Madam chair
um reasonably straightforward I think uh
it's been a combination of covid-19 and
uncertainty of travel and therefore a
higher travel costs because you had to
book a lot closer to the actual event
and the council has had
very strong and long association with
the Google country music club and the
the country music Queen event has
oscillated between
being in its own right and then the
young ambassador award the council ran
for some years and now it's back to the
queen
and given that the mere this time around
won't be traveling to town with I
thought that the requests seemed to be
reasonable in the in the circumstances
and
have these sufficient unique
circumstances at play to avoid a
repetition in the future so there's no
fear of creating a precedent
thank you
are there any questions please
Council Reed
I don't have a question
um but given that
Tamworth is their sister city I think it
behoves us to
send our country music Queen with um
every little bit of help she can get and
I'm sure she'll represent us very well
and I'm happy to move that
recommendation thank you councilor Reed
could any could I have a second it
I'm happy to check in the book can we um
second it on that recommendation that we
actually approve it
yes we can because the grants actually
are coming through this committee as
well so this is treated like
so you madam chair this will be a
recommendation that goes to full Council
for uh
I'm happy to sit in there
so does that mean we need to change this
recommendation
because we've got that the council
approve uh
not really uh Madam chair because you're
recommending the council proof and so
the minutes will have that
recommendation the recommendation from
this committee at the council proof it
goes to full Council and the council if
they agrees with that recommendation
then it's approving it and it's past
okay thank you then clarification
so we have a mover and a secondary are
we all in favor
can we we have some discussions
no no we know we're getting along in the
the tooth with the
um so there's a couple of I guess points
to point out here that I just would love
some clarification on the first I don't
need any clarification but
um the country music Queen has actually
already gone and spent this money
already
um so I understand that there's not much
precedence in that happening again but
it does set a dangerous precedence about
people spending money ahead of the
council approving it so I just wanted to
make councils very aware of that the
second point was it says that the the
committee has a surplus of seventeen
thousand and fifty dollars
um
so was that the overall cost was that
then
close to two and a half Grand is that
correct for those flights
checking the numbers there
yeah so yeah sorry yeah yeah yeah sorry
very different numbers
um yeah I guess I just wanted to make
counselors aware that it just if we
approved us um it opens us up to kind of
a president that you can spend Council
money and then ask for forgiveness
rather than permission
um that's the only only issue that I
have with this but I do hear councilor
reads points around
um they are our sister city and the
country music Queen is a good Initiative
for the council I just
would you like
to counselor Phillips I think this is
probably one of those things that
because it they weren't attending last
year that possibly it hasn't come I'm
not sure how it's worked in the past
perhaps it's a question for the chief
executive has this ever happened before
when it's been retrospectively granted
uh three minutes no I think the key
thing here is that the Anarchy and off
again can we travel uh the data letter
was nine December by that stage we
pretty much had closed down for the year
and I think
um
you've got to place yourself in the
shoes of the requester they're probably
not aware of the intricacies of council
government processes and the fact that
this Council wouldn't have been meeting
until February and they possibly thought
it could have been signed off by myself
for the mayor But ultimately educated
the full Council so as worship's point
is is taken but I think in this case
it's just they had they had a commitment
to go and obviously we're hoping the
council would fund it but the data the
letter suggests that they were in a
static quandary and probably you know
didn't realize that the council if you
met you missed the December agenda you
wouldn't put this before Council until
or committee should I say until February
foreign
chair I think it's important too that
the leader does request for sponsorship
um they're asking so we can decline and
the committee would use a surplus fund
so take the point but I think we've all
got our eyes wide open on this one
that's a
the situation that's Arisen and here
travel is increased so I support the
recommendation
thank you councilor High student
councilor Phillips
the humidity
I'm
three years ago six years ago we had a
grants committee
we hit it we had a basic idea about the
money that was coming to us cost wise
currently now we're just getting up
these sort of situations and we just had
a presentation earlier on for 25k
Without Really any knowledge of what a
budget would be for the from the staff
for the for the year what could be
Surplus and what could be burnt out
so this could be a case of
um we could put it in the ground as a
permanent one thousand dollar Grant off
for the flight for the flights for the
for the Tamworth Queen to go to Tamworth
uh year by year as part of the grants
but we haven't got a list if you know
what I mean before we did we had a rough
idea of what we what their grants were
again going to come up to what were what
they were
a rough order of cost but currently now
we're just sort of pulling things out of
the sky
you know how far do we go in the year
you know do we do we get to a point
where we've spent a hundred thousand
dollars in
Grants no I don't think so but would it
be sort of prudent that we have some
sort of rough order of idea
of cost for the year I'll just pass it
over to the CEO uh 311 chair the council
has a schedule of Grants and it's listed
in its annual plan in ltp and that's the
schedule of the amounts and the
organizations to receive those grants
and they are pretty much year on year
these requests uh give either one-offs
and um you're right counts to Phillips
we did have a grant subcommittee and it
in my humble view would proved to be
very effective because it was a a
gatekeeper on behalf of the council and
requests were funneled through that
subcommittee it's new request for
funding and we have a funding
application form
but that particular subcommittee uh fell
away following the 2020 floods change of
CFO Isis started alert and lifted CFO
then of course Luke departed and then we
had the floods and then we had a focus
on
repair and
so the disc committee I believe
could or the council should encourage a
a grant subcommittee to be established
and pick out the work the good work the
former community did it committee did
and the idea behind that is to status
file a council that
grants currently made those
organizations are still fit for purpose
and appropriate and secondly to be the
first protocol to ascertain The
credibility of any funding requests that
may come through the door so we don't
have a pool of money that's just spear
that the council can allocate we have
set grants that have still the test of
time for for Council to continue to
invest in and then we have these others
that come through the door through
various
guises that require the council to make
a decision on but the grant subcommittee
is the ideal vehicle to that for that to
happen
and I think we do need further
discussion about a grants committee yes
Rex
can I just did to the chief executive's
comments and it was actually a topical
conversation that the Senior Management
teams meeting on Monday with regards to
how we may wish to have this broader
conversation with Council as part of an
LGBT discussion and is part of where it
fits in with the activities the
allocation and then as the chief
Executives mentioned the subcommittee of
course a grant subcommittee to to be
able to deliver on what has worked
through that lgp process
councilor Hotel
we do of course have a community grants
policy of 2012 and in summary what it
says is that the council may consider
applications
um outside of the long-term or annual
planning process
for sums up to two thousand dollars
if it's above that then it must be
considered as part of the next annual
plan interestingly that if it is over
the two thousand dollars then a copy of
order to financial statements need to be
submitted as part of any requests for
funds I guess what I'm trying to
highlight is that it's a policy of 2012.
it's overdue to be looked at again and
so I think the wider consideration of
the way that we deal with Community
grants needs to have regard to that
policy too
Council heisted just in response to
councilor Phillips I think you know we
talk about 800 here for this particular
situation and the earlier situation you
refer to the 25 000
um that's why it's so important that the
recommendation that the chair moved
ensured that there was considered as
part of an annual plan process because
grants committee or not we need a budget
and we need to have our eye on the total
budget and the time to do that as annual
playing so we haven't in fact approved
the 25k that's got to get through the
annual plan process and with all the
other challenges we're going to face at
that time so I have a bit of confidence
here and this is an 800 one off for
nothing
um points well made but
we should probably move on
thank you counselor you worship sorry I
don't mean to slow it down right and I
know it is a sum of money that falls
lower than the policy but we are coming
into an annual plan where we are going
to look at a significant rate rise so
any dollar will count
um so I think a grants committee needs
to be seriously considered here
um at a matter of
urgency so we can get on top of some of
our other grants um so we've got lesser
workload come annual plan time
um to sort through those those grants
some of which we may need to cut back on
at least this year um to look out for
our rate payers
um so I guess I'd like to add to the
recommendation if if I could that
um
uh
uh sorry move the move the motion
um heavy to move the motion that we
provide Financial system the sum of 800
but also
um that uh the council um considers a
have you already moved the motion sorry
could I please uh add a recommendation
then of
um
if if that one is to pass uh of us
setting up a grants committee at the
council but we can go through the first
motion first and then add a second
recommendation if that's wrong
so you'd like to move that we set up an
amend you want amend this recommendation
is that right you worship we can go
through this motion and then I can push
the second recommendation after after
this message sorry I didn't realize it
had been started I had
moved already
are you happy to amend that motion
are you happy to Second counselor
Richard mcvale
you did second it earlier on are you not
happy to Second this
okay I'm happy to Second it
so the the motion as it was changed was
the the one that's written there uh and
then also the council considers setting
up a um subcommittee a grant
subcommittee
it's moved and seconded and
I cannot just ask all in favor yeah
uh there's a movie ticket but I
understand the council Reed as the
initial mover was happy to go that way
but councilman Fowler second and wasn't
so perhaps for process Madam chair if
you put the original motion and then if
his worship wants to raise a
supplementary motion and to find a
second and then that can be at the
second of a separate vote
so okay
right so put the motion that the council
approve financial assistance in the sum
of eight hundred dollars to enable Gore
District Gore counts or country music
Queen to attend the Tamworth Country
Music Festival
which was in January 2023 and January
2003 I put that motion
um councilor Reed you happy to move that
motion and councilor Richmond fell
second
all in favor
now we have a supplementary motion that
Council sets up a grants committee to
look at
these These funds going forward is that
correct yes uh and as uh Council our
heisted rightly pointed out I would sit
under this committee that we're
currently in
this committee yes so you madam chair
let's see clarification
um
you're asking for a subcommittee to this
committee be established or are you
asking Council to establish a
subcommittee to this committee will you
also be asking and providing some
direction as to what the terms of
reference for that subcommittee are
uh and with respect to the membership of
that subcommittee is it the full
committee uh or is it as a sub
is is at least members then the this
full committee well like like from a
process perspective it is critical that
it is very clear to staff to provide
that guidance to then assist with the
writing of the report that will need to
come back to council to uh to fulfill
that request
the other thing I would ask is you give
consideration to if the grants
subcommittee is solely to look at the
existing grants or is it to look at the
amount of money that is in the grants
budget as per the current annual plan
all of those things that like need to be
provided with some guidance and and I
suppose Direction because I'm I'm unsure
sitting here today we're having some
responsibility for this as to what you
are asking a grant subcommittee to be
doing
I think the
um correct motion that you know you I
think you should be passing is that the
uh
establishment of a grant subcommittee it
is subject of a staff report who placed
on next Council agenda
because we have actually
the old Grant subcommittee had its terms
of reference and had quite a clear
mandate in which to operate which I
would resurrect and review and put as
part of that report that goes to the
council so it would include a trump a
smaller membership to be determined by
the this particular committee but all
the infrastructure was in place and it
can be resurrected but it just needs to
be formally constituted by the new
Council
so the supplementary
recommendation is that the establishment
of a grant subcommittee to be determined
by this committee
the motion would be that the
uh
the issue of the step the potential
establishment of a Grant's subcommittee
be the subject of a staff report to be
placed on the next Council agenda
letting agenda on a full full Council
not this committee full Council okay
that that report will make it clear that
once there's a committee subcommittee if
it's established will report back
through this committee
are you happy to move that you wish it
secondary Council of Phillips
all in favor or would you like the
recommendation read again
you're all happy with that
okay all in favor
carried
so our last item is the gore District
socio-economic data
Community campus Baseline report for
February 2023
would you like to speak to this
if we went to you I'll take you to dream
but I just want to highlight Four Points
I suppose first is paragraph 2.2 for for
correctness it was at its 21 February
extraordinary meeting the council
adopted the terms of reference there was
today so this report was written in
anticipation that it would have been
adopted a week ago but but I do want to
point out that the purpose of this
report is based on what the signed off
as part of those terms of reference
which was one of the key
responsibilities for this Committee in
those terms of references to monitor
data and forming the gore districts
socio-demographics and social climate to
assess current and future impacts so
that that's why this is here to fulfill
one of the key responsibilities of the
committee the second point I make is
that the source source of data is is
stated from dotlovesdata which is a
reputable data company which accesses
the information from a wide variety of
sources so over a wide period of time so
it is data that is valid and and has
been validated
the third point I would make uh refers
to put paragraph 2.7
which is really just again reiterating
that this is the start of a journey with
respect to this information
that it's Baseline data as of what we
what we have got and current data today
and actually the value of it for you as
a council and for other
external government agencies and other
other social external agencies who will
be interested in this will be what this
looks like in six months 12 months 18
months 24 months from a comparative
perspective
and as I've mentioned in the report
there on 2.8